the real swoop huh don't don't you
always have bangs in a way they're there
to hide foreheads I routinely do weird
things with my hair I bleached a stripe
had a weird rat tail had a a mullet if I
liked it I could see myself getting
bangs I'm gonna feel like self-conscious
a little bit more than I normally would
today I'm running an event for a pretty
high-profile client we've never
interacted face to face having banks in
a professional setting that's a little
dicey for me I got plenty of other
things to be self-conscious about I feel
like the hairs like way down the list
[Music]
feel like a caveman huh interesting
[Music]
when do I make my 1974 dating video tape
hello ladies
my name is Daniel I'm in sales I like
fine Italian cuisine 1960s rock guy but
like enough shitty band a Viking that
gets left behind vice principal I don't
know if I like it or hate it
it feels real heavy up here it's like
kind of highlighting my eyes do I not
really and I hope I don't pass out from
the heat
okay yes
cool well my first official interaction
with a human being wearing this the guy
was about as dismissive is as humanly
possible I guess banging it out fun to
fight though do you think I could ask my
wife what she would do if I came home
like this she did say that if I did do
it I should go get it done
professionally but I don't think is a
slam on you Jordan but you know don't
put your day job guys how my bank's
doing the horrible wake that you're
wearing I really don't think that you
should ever do this again
I just dealt with my clients and they
felt like I was just you know and if he
guided me through this feeling very
self-conscious Tran into a guy I hadn't
seen months and he did not notice a
thing different about me so does that
mean that I'm the guy that does this
sort of thing often enough that nobody
notices I feel like I'm learning more
about myself and you guys are learning
about bangs
the first person I showed gave me some
positive feedbacks and more people I was
like showing they were like making fun
of me basically there are some
visibility problems I also notice the
bangs are kinda sweaty the bangs got my
eyes less than my current hair does I
couldn't tell if people were looking at
me more different than they normally
would I was like kind of paranoid about
that I'm meeting people for the first
time that I've had like a lot of email
exchange with and their guys like oh wow
so you're a real businessman and you
look like some hippie guy these people
are never gonna call me back I thought
my confidence would be affected and it
ended up not being the case some people
don't like it as long as you like it
that's all that matters
[Music]